we've had all the feels here today on
the show this is like
my kind like that this is just so life
affirming
to me i really i mean it because i want
to laugh
i want to cry i want to feel i want to i
wanna make things
and um it's diy week here on the show
and listen in the last year we've all
had to up our diy game because no one
was coming
oh my god oh my god oh my god
help yourself or sink year so it felt
appropriate and then i we found out at
the show that you're obsessed with a
food vlogger who inspired you to cook
um oh no you know
do you have a marriott
is she is she on the show
miriam are you there
ladies and gentlemen please welcome
miriam greene
you so much for having me
oh my gosh sir first miriam my boyfriend
is going to fate
you don't understand i was like oh no i
want you to hear me carefully and what
you do to people my boyfriend
is i didn't know who you were from a
hole in the wall my boyfriend as i'm
sitting here writing
episodes of whatever or writing whatever
it is that i'm writing
trying to find the voice of billie
holiday he
would pull me out of it by watching this
girl i'm like who is this girl why
what are you doing and then i became an
addict
too because i am an addict i sit there
and watch you
and obsess with you i love you and i
am not since susan lucci from all my
children have i been this excited to me
i got to tell you this is a big deal
this is a big big deal for me oh my god
hello how are you
looking at me like i'm crazy by the way
i'm just so happy to hear a susan lucci
reference
but i have to tell you something you
bring so much joy
to people uh drew you gotta follow her i
have to thank you lee
because of the show and our um
little rabbit hole into your entire
world
i discovered miriam through you and i
just want to thank you because miriam
your choice in um culinary
recipes is all the things that i want i
want to smear my food
all over my body it's like i know it's
going there anyway
so i'm glad that there's this joy that
gets to happen before it ends up
on my thighs and my stomach your food
is like it's my happy place
so thank you thank you thank you so
so so much i hear that there might be
like some noodles we can all slurp i'm
seeing it in the monitor i'm salivating
is it true oh my god polly oh my god
it's true lee
do you have some noodles oh my god oh my
god
it's hot oh my god oh my god lee do you
have some noodles
i have my noodles i have my noodles
like miriam and my noodles always
offer your audience some always okay so
what do we do yeah come on darling
come on baby come on daddy miriam
oh my god lee what do we say
it is what
this is so wonderful miriam i can't
thank you enough
and can we get this recipe on your wait
miriam can we get this did you cook this
is it on your is this
can we get this recipe on your darling
yes of course
i think i saw i think i watched a video
of you making it and
we're going to promote you on the home
page and you're just such a rock star so
much
thank you so much for joining us today
miriam
if at any time you guys want to get
together and cook at any time
have your people call my people fabulous
also we should do a cooking segment
together okay miriam just
you have no idea you have no idea hello
darling
i'm here for you okay thank you so much
miriam for joining us and surprisingly
and thank you guys thank you oh my god
it was so good
first of all please tell clara i send
all of my love
and i'm so grateful to her watching i
adore you thank you so much for having
me on
your family because you are every bit of
the life that i
that i imagined god bless you and god
bless your continued success
and when you want to come back to acting
i can't wait to direct you
seriously that might be the
first time my phone rang with like the
ultimate filmmaker
thank you seriously i just think you're
so good and
um i just think you have so much to give
to the world
as an artist you are one of the world's
talents so
don't forget that and remember that that
is what is in you
so um i love you and i can't i hope that
you see that one day
i want people to um
share their experiences so that we can
feel connected i'm always looking for
the thing that connects us
and you know it's like life is short
and unzipping and revealing
i do believe is the key and it's a risk
but it's the one that rewards the most
so
thank you for doing that lee daniels and
i'm so glad that we could honor
all the aspects of lee daniels today
thank you united states versus billie
holiday is streaming now on hulu it's
extraordinary
[Music]
you